[Music]
so you know the entire world really
turns to the Kardashians for beauty tips
like we all copy everything you guys do
I love in your show that then you're
like walking in your life or JLo does
that it's like we're taking it to like a
level above Kardashian today is there
like if JLo could do something I can do
it right yeah like sharing that I know
we I didn't even realize they're
sleeping on your face thing thank you
wait well I had to learn to I was always
up like hell are these lines on the side
of my neck I'm too young for this what
is this and I was like are they aging
aging is up and down it's when there's
like you have lines in the side of your
neck it's from side sleeping what's the
biggest thing you've learned from JLo
for beauty I think yeah I mean well J
Lo's just I will I read about her like
if she gives an interview as they gotta
read it what are her beauty tips cuz
look at that woman you know she's
amazing it's not normal and while Khloe
turns to JLo for inspiration were
turning to Chloe to get us motivated to
hit the gym the thirty-three-year-old
Revenge body host is gearing up for the
season two premiere this Sunday on E I
lost a lot of confidence in myself I
found new me and this happiness and I
want to share it with other people I
never thought of my body as revenge I
just did something for myself I think
it's important to show people you can
turn your life around you can go through
hell and high water but you can still
come out and have a beautiful positive
happy life
[Music]
you